the first time I was catcalled I was
walking to my high school when I was 16
years old I was 25 I was 12 and I was a
child wolf-whistles how you doing
sweetheart shifting lewd comments asking
you to do sexual things to them I just
kept going I just kept walking I didn't
didn't do anything but I was terrified I
felt my body just burned hot with shame
I felt guilty it and I felt ashamed I
was 11 years old
it was a teenaged is mr. Rowan Blanchard
who showed her first Catco memory a few
weeks ago with interview magazine a
journalist her name's Alana vagya nose
was impressed by the young woman's story
and created the hashtag first time I was
kept cold
alanna virgin was decided that she wants
to dispel once and for all the myth that
kept calling is a compliment for women
and not that big of a deal catcalling
has become normalized something that you
know moms have to teach their daughters
to just look down on the ground and
don't say anything for fear of you know
maybe a violent backlash um I mean it's
terrifying it's horrible
you
what I wish for in a perfect world after
discussing street harassment and
catcalling online is that it would stop
um I understand that that's not going to
happen overnight but I think little by
little when we have these conversations
we chip away at a larger issue